it's certainly possible as today's
analysis shows that we could be running
the system very tight this winter and
incidentally even tighter the winter
after that but industry will be doing
everything possible to help manage its
demand to so that this bad situation
isn't made any worse than it needs to be
and industries like steel and chemical
manufacturers if they've got flexibility
and when they can use their power we'll
use it off peak if they can and try and
reduce the demand on the system when
it's under stress could be fine though
couldn't we
we could be all right if we have
relatively warm weather like we're
enjoying at the moment an unusually mild
uh end to autumn if that carries on
through the winter and there are no
failures uh of any other plant
in power generation then we may be lucky
particularly if the wind blows as well
but as we know from the past we can have
prolonged cold snaps when the wind
level around the british isles is and
northwest europe in fact is very low so
we get very low output from the heavily
expensively subsidized wind turbines
which produce a lot of energy on average
but not necessarily when we need it and
that's when we could be in trouble and
just to clarify um
domestic consumers could find themselves
in a position where they are subsidizing
big business
i wouldn't quite put it like that if
they were it would certainly be a
problem what what we're faced with is a
situation where we have a lack of
generating capacity potentially
and if it's cheaper to get industry to
reduce its demand than it is to get more
capacity on the system burning gas or
coal to keep the lights on and actually
will actually be cheaper for the for the
domestic consumer and other businesses
than the alternative but of course we
shouldn't be in this situation in the
first place and uh energy-intensive
businesses uh other manufacturing
companies and domestic consumers alike
we need we all need secure energy
supplies we need to get going fast in
building replacement gas-fired power
stations and in the long run nuclear to
replace the older plant that's coming to
the end of its life